-In celebration of
Memorial Day weekend
and the start of
summer grilling season,
Tariq and I are going to have
a friendly competition.
It's time for the first annual
"Tonight Show" Hot Dog-Off.
-♪ Hot dog on a grill ♪
♪ Hot dog on a grill ♪
[ Both laugh ]
-The rules are very simple.
We'll each assemble
the perfect summer hot dog.
We get to pick the bun,
the toppings, and sauces.
Whoever makes the most
delicious one is the wiener.
Ha ha.
[ Laughter ]
Most importantly,
they get their name
engraved on "The Tonight Show"
Golden Hot Dog Trophy.
Where is it?
[ Crowd oohs ]
Wow. Unbelievable.
You ready for this, Tariq?
-Whatever.
-Yeah. Alright, here we go.
But first, let's meet our judges
to decide the winning hot dog.
We have some
very special guests.
Please welcome the cast
of the "Kids Tonight Show."
Recker Eans, Dylan Gilmer,
Mykal-Michelle Harris,
and Olivia Perez!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Buddy!
-Look at you!
-Good to see you guys!
Come on, pal.
-Good to see you.
-Good to see you, too.
-Thank you for being here.
Now, what are
your qualifications
for being the judges
of a hot dog competition?
-Well, you know,
I would say that, you know,
my taste buds
really cradle the hot dog,
and so it makes me perfect
for the hot dog eating contest.
-And I'm an 11-year-old kid
and I'm growing.
So, I mean,
who doesn't love a hot dog?
-Facts!
-I mean, come on.
-Okay! That's what I'm
talking about. Alright.
Well, to be sure it's a fair
and balanced contest,
judges, please leave the studio
and head over
to the isolation room.
It's right over there.
-Scary!
-[ Laughing ]
♪♪
-Whoa.
-Alright, judges,
make sure you put on
the Domes of Silence.
[ Laughter ]
Okay, there you go.
Now, they cannot see
or hear what we're about to do.
Now, I thought a lot
about this recipe.
I will make mine first, okay?
This one is --
I think I'm gonna win.
I'm calling this
one the Summer Vacation Dog.
[ Cheers and applause ]
"Dog Day Afternoon."
Hot Dog Day Afternoon.
In the summertime,
you want a little bit
of everything, right?
Oop. Geez. Something's burning.
Alright.
Alright,
so here's what I'm gonna do.
I cut my --
cut my hot dog in half, right?
Look at this.
Yeah, completely in half, right?
Now I'm going to boil one
in 0.0 non-alcoholic beer.
Yeah, no alcohol.
So I'm boiling that one.
That's boiled.
The other one, I'm going to fry
in oil and butter.
So, look, that's frying up
right there.
Tariq, are you getting
nervous already, bud?
-I'm very nervous.
-Yeah. Look at that.
You want to get a nice little
sizzle on there, okay?
So once that's done,
you got the boil part,
you put the boil part
in, right?
Then you put the fried part in.
It's going to look like that.
Okay, then I put
a little Spaghetti-Os.
Now, I would I would warm
the Spaghetti-Os up myself.
So put that in the pan,
warm it up a little bit.
[ Sizzling ]
Ooh, it's start --
you it's ready
when it starts to spit back.
[ Laughter ]
So you put a little Spaghetti-Os
on there, right?
Oh, yeah. Put a little mustard
on there as well.
A little mustard
and then Spaghetti-Os, right?
And then to finish it off
and assure the win,
crushed Doritos.
Look at this.
Alright, so, look.
Crush them.
Make sure they're on top
right there.
Crush this. There you go.
This is it. My hot dog.
The Summer Vacation Dog,
right there.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-That's all well and good,
Jimmy,
but I think I've got this one
in the bag with the Boss Dog.
[ Cheers ]
-Good name.
-First, I'm going to fry up
my Kobe beef hot dog.
-You're so fancy. Kobe beef.
-Yeah.
-Yeah, kids love Kobe beef.
-While that's cooking up,
I'm gonna go ahead, I'm gonna
add a little sauerkraut.
-Sauerkraut?
-A little bit.
-Alright, I'm just saying, man.
Your kids like sauerkraut?
-My kids love sauerkraut, Jimmy.
My kids have a, you know,
a highly developed palate.
-Yeah, yeah, okay.
-Okay.
Okay. Sauerkraut first?
-A little kraut.
-Yeah.
-Don't want the kraut to be dry.
Hit it with a little relish.
Sweeten it up.
Sweeten the pot a little.
-[ Laughing ]
-A little relish.
-What sauerkraut is dry?
-Okay, I'mma flip this guy.
-Yeah. It's about time.
-Get his little sear on there.
-Mm!
-Okay.
But I got one
that's done already, so.
-We both decided to butterfly.
those dogs.
-I know, right?
But you cut yours in half.
-Completely, yeah.
-Mine is just butterflied,
so I'm able to sort of nestle
more ingredients
into the cut,
into the little crevasse.
-Uh-huh. Would you like some
Doritos or something?
-Oh, no, no. No Doritos.
I'mma do, you know,
a standard little mustard.
-Yeah.
-Keep it old school.
-Okay, good, good, good.
-Secret weapon.
A little truffle oil.
[ Crowd oohs ]
-Don't tell me that, man.
-Right?
-Truffle oil?
-The kids are going to
freak out.
-I'm gonna do some
edible flowers.
-What's wrong with you?
[ Cheers ]
What is wrong with you, man?
-Look, Jimmy, Jimmy.
-What's wrong with you, dude?
-This isn't the Costco
$1.50 dog and a soda.
[ Laughter ]
[ Applause ]
I'mma top it with
a little gold leaf.
-Gold? What is wrong with you?
Gold leaf?
-Yes.
This is a decadent,
decadent dog.
-That is a decadent dog.
You think kids
are going to like this?
-They're going to love it.
-Okay.
What do you call this again?
-This is the Boss Dog.
-Alright.
I like the Boss Dog.
There you go.
Let's put them next to
each other.
Alright, there they are
next to each other,
our two hot dogs.
Okay, now, this is going
to be a tough decision.
The judges may now exit
the isolation room
and take their place
at the judges table.
Alright.
[ Applause ]
-Alright, judges, alright.
It is now
time to try the hot dogs.
Whenever you're ready, Recker,
we'll start with you.
-[ Laughing ]
-Oh, my God.
-Wait, are those
like, mac and cheese?
Is that mac and cheese? Okay.
-I love the gold.
-Here we go.
-Okay.
-How is it?
-Is it good?
-It's like, okay. It doesn't
have much flavor, though.
-Dang.
-Yeah, I agree. I agree.
I hear you.
I hear what you're saying.
He's got to be honest.
-You're right.
-Okay.
-It's up to you, bud, go.
-Alright.
So I like the consistency.
The bun is really soft.
-That's my man.
-Okay.
I'm gonna put some
ketchup on it.
-Alright.
-Nice ketchup.
-Okay.
-Okay. Okay.
Oh. [ Laughing ]
-Yeah. Get a real bite.
-Mm. Mnh-mnh.
Oh, that looks messy.
-Mnh-mnh.
-Oh, alright. Okay.
-You don't like it?
-Okay. Alright.
[ Laughter ]
-I'm scared now!
-Oh, no.
-Don't be scared. Go for it.
Mykal-Michelle,
let's see what you got.
-Whoever made this,
it's like a kid,
because it's like,
Doritos all over it.
-Mykal-Michelle, don't you
like that stuff?
-It's like like someone my age
made it.
-Get a big bite. Yeah.
-Ohh.
-Oh, yeah. I'm loving it.
-Oh, the aftertaste.
-I feel like the mustard
gives it a zing.
-Mm! Mm.
-Pretty good?
Do you like it?
-It's like --
Ooh. Okay. Hold on.
[ Laughter ]
-Olivia, go for it.
Tell me what you think.
-Okay. Wow.
The looks look --
very interesting.
Wow.
-Yeah. Kindergarten.
-Oh, no.
You can tell she don't
like that.
-Oh, man.
-I like how we're all agreeing.
-Wow.
-You can spit it in
something if you want.
-That's an A for effort.
-A for effort! Nice, not bad.
-A for effort.
-Thank you, thank you.
-Now, let's please try
hot dog number two.
-Wait, why is there, like, gold?
Are these, like --
are these candy wrappers?
-This is like,
Mr. Gordon Ramsay, like...
[ Cheers ]
-Mwah! Chef's kiss.
-Oh, okay, okay.
That's a good sign.
-That has way more flavor.
But the texture -- I don't know
what you put on this, but...
alright.
-That's the review,
is "alright"?
-Yeah. I don't know
what happened there.
-Okay, bun is really hard
on this one.
Okay. I'm not liking that.
It's crispy.
Okay, I'll give you
an A for the design.
You know, the gold.
You know, it definitely
matches my style.
-Presentation is everything.
-It matches my style.
I'm loving it. Okay.
[ Laughing ]
-That was a big bite.
Oh, whoa.
Whoa.
Your total,
like, hot dog fell out.
-I'm not liking it, you know?
-This bun feels like
it's like a pretzel bun.
It feels really good.
-Alright, let's see.
-Oh, oh, whoa.
Big bite there.
[ Laughter ]
-So it goes in your mouth
pretty easily.
You can eat it pretty easily,
yeah?
-Mm-hmm.
-Yeah, of course.
-I taste sweetness?
It's like, it's very sweet.
Very sweet.
-In the gold?
-Kind of tastes like candy.
a little bit.
-Oh, okay.
-The gold also
gives it kind of a crunch.
-Okay.
-Alright.
Olivia, it's down to you.
Let's see what you think.
-The visual,
I love how this person
paid attention to the bun.
It's, like, perfectly cooked.
Love that.
Okay, so we got some flowers.
-That kid, she knows this stuff.
-Gold.
Oh, wow.
-Oh, she didn't even bite it!
-Wow, that was...
-Wow.
-Interesting.
Those gold flakes,
they were a little salty.
-Too much flavor, alright.
-Yeah. Yeah.
-You'd rather have too much
flavor, though, then no flavor.
-You never know. You never know.
-Because the second one
had way more flavor.
I like that.
-But like,
you're doing too much, though.
You know?
-Yeah.
-Sometimes you gotta slow down.
-Trying a little too hard.
-If any hot dog
was doing too much,
it's probably the one
with the Spaghetti-Os on it.
All you got to get
is that's me getting old.
-I feel like the Spaghetti-Os
wasn't hitting.
-Please write down
and consensus on that.
Was it hot to number one?
Don't show us.
Or hot dog number two?
-Huddle, huddle.
-And then put the ballot
into the official
"Tonight Show" Hot Dog-Off
ballot box.
Is it hot dog number one
or hot dog number two?
-Okay. Okay. Okay.
-Alright. Very good.
-Lock it.
-Oh, yeah.
Put the straitjacket on it.
-I need help! I need help!
-Lock it
and put the cage over it.
So now it is locked.
It is securely locked
in that ballot box.
-No one can see what
we just did.
-Now let's reveal
what's in the box.
Take it back out.
Yeah. Take the cage off.
Take the cage off.
Sorry about that. Apologize.
We went too hard.
Yeah. It just opens. Yeah.
Alright, here we go.
-Okay.
-The winner is...
The wiener is...
-Number one!
-That is my dog!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Wow.
Congrats to "The Tonight Show"
Hog Dog-Off champion, me!
You are the best judges.
Thanks again to our
very special judges.